welcome to the final lecture of the
Dwight Terry lecture series this fall
given by the distinguished historian of
science professor janet brown titled
becoming darwin history memory and
biography since this is the final
lecture before we proceed I just wanted
to give a word of thanks to heather
calabresi and her team members who have
been working behind the scenes to make
this a great success and also I want to
thank the office of the secretary at
Yale University for providing the
support for this amazing series so let's
thank all the people working behind the
scenes even before we start thanks
Heather we've had the pleasure and
delight of hearing in the previous two
lectures about very interesting facets
of Darwin's life and his character from
Professor Brown first we learned of his
impeccable record keeping that extended
into his personal life as well as in his
scientific work in the second lecture we
heard about accounts including his own
of his scientific life and today we will
be hearing more about the iconography
and the imagery the construction of the
image of Darwin as well as not not
unrelated the establishment of him as a
scientific icon iconic scientists and
what really makes one whether it is the
radicalness of their ideas the impact of
their ideas or their broader engagement
in the public sphere are all very very
interesting questions but they are
completely intertwined with the
construction of the image the persona of
the scientist after their life the BBC
to the poll a few years ago to rank
scientific icons in the world and as you
can probably imagine the three names
that filtered up we're Newton
Darwin and Einstein Darwin's ideas on
evolution as we have heard from Jala
shook the world in an incredibly unique
way as they contested a pre-existing
account for the origin of life one that
wielded enormous authority so in terms
of the transformative nature of his
ideas Darwin clearly has had the
roughest ride of the three icons that I
mentioned but in terms of the
iconography and the image of Darwin I'm
very curious to hear about Darwin's sage
look versus Einstein's unkempt hair at
any rate I'm sure like me you're waiting
eagerly to hear from Professor Brown
about Darwin's the construction of
Darwin's image and the iconography
without further ado I would like to
invite Janet to give the final Terry
lecture of the series
thank you very much both for that
generous welcome and for all turning out
on this rainy afternoon which is also a
holiday so I do appreciate it thank you
for being here and I do want to
reiterate and say again how very kind
and efficient and thoughtful the Terry
committee have been and I would like to
say once again thank you for the
invitation I've been thrilled bits to
accept so I'm very glad to be here and
today has already suggested I'm going to
be reflecting on some of the portraits
and the public commemorations of Charles
Darwin and what this might have
signified for the distribution and the
assimilation of his ideas of the great
laws of nature as requested by the terms
of the telly lectureship I'm actually
going to talk about these three pictures
here it seems to me that many of the
commemorative endeavors of the past 150
years as they related to Darwin can be
regarded as ways of grappling with the
question of how to assimilate his ideas
and how to present his very
controversial achievements to the
general public especially at times like
today when large numbers of individuals
may not believe in evolution of any kind
so the controversy that originally
surrounded evolutionary ideas has never
really gone away even 150 years later
and my plan this evening is to look at
some of the portraits and the mass media
images of Darwin that were produced in
the
english-speaking world as well as the
foundation of a museum in his home in
England before turning to consider some
of the ways we encountered Darwinism in
America today the story is necessarily
linked to the ebb and flow of the
acceptance of Darwinism and as you can
imagine many portraits were made of
Darwin during his lifetime in different
media including pastels watercolors oils
lithography engravings caricatures which
we mustn't forget and early photography
the earliest images were made for family
eyes alone of which this is the most
charming Pascal drawing of Darwin age 7
and his younger sister Catherine it's
one of a set of the Darwin children made
in 1816 and their mother Susannah Darwin
died the year after this was drawn
perhaps a more well-known one is the one
which we've seen already quite a number
of times and you've seen endlessly which
is actually part of my talk today this
is the most well-known picture of Darwin
as a young man and sometimes referred to
as the Beagle portrait which is just by
chance it was the only other known
picture apart from the info picture of
Darwin a seven year old it's the only
other painting of him taken around the
time of the Beagle voyage this was
actually done for years after the Beagle
returned back to Great Britain it's one
of the pair that we saw on Tuesday last
week made around 1840 to mark his
marriage in 1839 to his cousin emma
wedgwood and the pair of portraits was
requested by Emma Darwin sister
Elizabeth to hang in the family wedgwood
home in Staffordshire it was never
really hung in Darwin's home it was for
relatives to
to look at and the point here is that
some portraiture is for domestic
consumption and as Walter Benjamin
insisted the uniqueness of a work of art
controls its history if something is
unique it has a particular kind of
history if something is mechanically
reproduced and spread it has another
kind of history and as the Beagle voyage
became increasingly significant in the
public imagination some of the books I
spoke about on Thursday the Beagle
voyage was a very important element of
the way that Darwin's knife was told and
as the voyage became more significant so
this portrait was increasingly made
public was a private portrait remember
that it then became public through
reproduction as the technologies
diversified and improved it was
reproduced in books first in black and
white then in color in slideshows public
lectures starting from nineteen oh nine
onwards TV documentaries especially
those relating to the Galapagos
Archipelago museum displays and
elsewhere so with continued replication
it's become what we might even call
democratized and it's available in
modern memories in ways that would be
impossible for the original 24 the
originals originally concerned so this
image and others of Darwin have become
emancipated from their origins they've
been given fresh meanings and they've
been placed in situations where it would
be impossible for the single unique
original to go now just show you a
couple of places here this is a tattoo
on the left I don't know maybe you can
guess what part of their Natalie this is
is it someone's shoulder blade and then
it's been photographed with masks around
it I'm not entirely sure but it's a
tattoo somebody has hacked Darwin's
beagle face tattooed on their body more
often it's the I think evolutionary tree
on somebody's shoulder but this is very
unusual and then endless mugs t-shirts
and various ways of reproducing Darwin's
face for those people who wish to have
him in their daily life and I thank one
of the Yale graduate students for
directing me to Darwin's Twitter site
that now I took this off last week so
it's probably out of date now but you
can see there's quite a lot of people
asking Darwin questions and he responds
yeah I have to say if luck is only one
little earthquake haven't happened I
felt my best my bed slightly vibrate in
a lateral direction so he's responding
and I don't know who does some it is
something obviously and there's a
similar private portrait a photograph
this time that became public during
Darwin's lifetime that was Julia
Margaret Cameron photograph of Darwin
taken in eighteen sixty eight when he
was on a family holiday on the Isle of
Wight which is to the south of Britain
where she lived and Julia Margaret
Cameron purpose in the left-hand one
that's an original so to speak the
others are mechanically reproduced the
purpose was to photograph a number of
intellectuals and creative minds and to
show their intellectuality the power of
their minds through the kind of peaceful
repose of the photograph she took
Tennyson Alfred Jefferson she took the
astronomer John Herschel she took Robert
Browning and she took some other eminent
men her photographs of women were
completely different very strong
gendering in her imagery the women were
all dressed up as maids of chalant other
kinds of historic scenes that she was
keen to replicate darling was very
pleased with this portrait and he
provided an endorsement in his honed own
handwriting that can sometimes be seen
underneath the picture which is oh sorry
which is here and it's a poor
reproduction I do apologize and his it's
from a letter that she wrote to Cameron
and she got it lithographed and then
applied to the prince
I like this photograph very much better
than any other which has been taken with
me and then it's signed Chuck Darwin
Charles Darwin so Cameron sold these
photographs the intention was to sell
them in limited numbers blind stamps on
them at Cole nagas gallery in Bond
Street in London and this is one of
those here so she's had his signature
reproduced and then made under copyright
Julia Margaret Cameron provided her
family with quite an income it's an
evocative portrait there were three or
four sittings at least three or four
exposures taken during the one sitting
and it appears on the English ten-pound
note and here on the right that will be
taken out of circulation fairly shortly
so you should get if you want your
Darwin on a ten-pound note really he's
going to be shunted off next year and we
don't know who's going on yet or least I
don't know so the Cameron has been
reproduced many times and the oddest
place that I've come across it is in the
ticket hall of a provincial railway
station in Great Britain brockenhurst in
Hampshire England so he gets everywhere
and it's rather astonishing to think why
a railway station might have hung an
image of Darwin on our members there
were two other photographs of Darwin
that became an integral part of the
story in the visual legacy this is one
of them on the left here it was taken by
Darwin's son Leonard who was a very
enthusiastic home photographer with all
the early equipment and it's Darwin
seated on the tessellated floor the
veranda of the house in Kent where he
lived for decades and decades it was
reproduced very many times
copiously we might even say as a woodcut
and a steel engraving here and formed
the frontispiece to several of the
biographies that came out relating to
Darwin that I discussed the other day
there's another one that you'll also
recognize it's a slightly different
exposure here here is Darwin taken the
very end of his life he didn't know it
was the end of his life again on the
veranda at down house wearing this cape
that becomes quite an important visual
signifier of his occupations and age and
also his status as an independent
privately financed gentleman and then
that was slightly different you can see
his head is more turned was engraved and
again turned up as frontis pieces in
many different kinds of published works
so the boundary between private and
public was already blurred before Darwin
even deceased he was a celebrity by the
time he died so most of the other
portraits of Darwin and the statues that
are turned to in a moment were
deliberately produced for public display
as evolutionary ideas became more widely
disseminated during his lifetime he
became one of the first scientific
celebrities and his image could be found
in an increasingly wide variety of
places and in meet different media and
the will not particularly want to
address because of its prominence in our
minds today is this very exceptional
portrait oil portrait painted by the
artist john collier in 1881 from life
and subsequently multiplied many many
times and in many media it was painted
by subscription at the request of the
linnean society of london whose members
raised a fund to commission kaalia
kaalia was thomas henry hun thomas henry
huxley son-in-law he had married
Huxley's daughter Marion and was a
member of the pre-raphaelites set in
central London he Collier and his wife
Marion because they had social relations
with Darwin came to stay in darwin's
house whilst the sketches were being
made for this portrait marion was an
excellent artist herself and she made a
pencil sketch of Darwin during that
visit that I think is very evocative
it's really unusual to see something so
relaxed in in the Darwin portraiture and
now the linnean society had many reasons
to consider Darwin as their most
prominent member on July 1858 you recall
at the linnean society was the place in
which the double contribution from
Charles Darwin and Alfred Russel Wallace
was read to the members it first
proposed evolution by natural selection
in the meeting room of the linnean
society and Darwin remained a very
active contributor to the linnean
society until his death so by hanging
Darwin on their walls the society was
making several claims for scientific
attention not least to bolster the
important role of Natural History in an
increasingly experimental biological
science so the portrait which I'm just
going to go back to here Darwin's
portrait on the left was saying things
to members
in the meeting room of the linnean
society that here we have our most
famous member and I wanted to just
mention before I talk to them about the
Huxley portrait the social network that
lay behind koleos portrait of Darwin was
really extensive the president of the
linnean society was John Lubbock who was
Darwin's close friend and neighbor in
Kent the Society's secretary who had
raised the subscription money was
Darwin's favorite disciple George
ramana's and presumably Colliers
relationship with Huxley was a strong
factor in the allocation of the
Commission so it's worth noting that
there was in 1881 when this portrait was
painted there was no comparable ground
swell of opinion to financially support
a portrait of Alfred Russel Wallace
their mission was only rectified in 1998
with a large portrait of Wallace by
Roger Remington that now hands next to
the collier in the linnean society
meeting rooms so Wallace was kind of
written out of the story but he was
overlooked until nineteen ninety-eight
when a commissioned portrait was made of
him so this Darwin portrait was copied
three times twice by collier in the next
30 years for other institutions
including the royal society which had
forgotten to commission a portrait of
Darwin during his lifetime so colonist
taste for the theatrical is plainly
demonstrated here Darwin's shown full
face a magnificent beard which for many
people then and now still has resonances
of a saintly frame of mind
patriarchal could even be godly in its
magnificence it's a beard that we do
need to recognize is playing a role in
the picture and his clothes are just an
impression of a cloak and a hat I'm
afraid the this is a reproduction of the
Royal Society copy rather than the one
in the National Portrait Gallery which
is a bit red around the back so you
can't see but there is a cloak and his
holding a hat here his hand he's clearly
ready to go out for a walk and that
actually was collier's intention to show
him away from his desk away from the
mental work that usually went into
scientific creation but here he is a
private individual gentleman on his way
out for a walk in the natural world but
nevertheless his one who saw further
into nature than his contemporaries so
we had Darwin who's really very
magisterial and mysterious in this and
Huxley which dear I'm sorry perhaps can
see that better from afar than I can
Huxley's leaving rather insolently up
against a table with some books
underneath his arm and his dangling this
human skull and is ready for a fight so
the way that they're represented is
different but both intellectuals they're
both scientists they're both no
background behind them the intention is
for you to understand that these were
thinking people but they're thinking
slightly different things and in
Darwin's I would just draw your
attention to the way that the eyes have
become the focus of the portrait which
isn't unusual for portraiture but
nevertheless one of darwin's doctors
went on record saying that Darwin was
all eyes he was always watching always
observing
and I think that this Collier portrait
has a lot to did have a lot to say to
it's a first audience and that has has
had things to say to us over the decades
that are very powerful so this was I
cannot raphy that was designed to
impress and in similar fashion there
were several towns in Great Britain who
were had been associated with Darwin
during his lifetime who engaged in
competition after his death to erect a
statue so here is the statue in
Shrewsbury which was darlings birthplace
the statues rather a handsome seated
bronze Darwin its life size is taken
from that photograph by Darwin son
Leonard and here is the opening ceremony
with all the worthy Shrewsbury i'ts
milling around happy to commemorate
Darwin in their own town there are other
Darwin images again taken from
photographs this is the oxford
university natural history museum they
commissioned a standing darwin to match
the other standing images that are sort
of holding up the roof in the inner
courtyard it's rather loosely
interpreted because there is no image of
Darwin standing so casually with his
feet crossed like that all his hands
crossed on his chest it's imaginary and
this is him unlike shows me this museum
was not where Darwin had been born and
in fact Darwin had not been men and it
was the location of the clash in 1860
between Huxley and Bishop Wilberforce at
which Huxley is thought to have said we
don't know the exact words but he's
thought to have said that he had rather
have an ape through grandfather than a
bishop who twisted the truth like little
force
and so the purpose of the statue in
Oxford is very different from the
purpose of the statue in Shrewsbury it's
highlighting the triumph of rational
science over here in North America
American biologists had a slightly
different agenda they wished to show
that they too were part of the big swing
towards Darwinism and the new york
academy of sciences commissioned the
artist william cooper to produce a
portrait bust which is on the left here
in 1909 and it was displayed at the
American Museum of Natural History at
their 1909 Darwinian Darwin celebrations
and in a new Hall of invertebrate
zoology that was named the Darwin Hall
it doesn't exist now but it did then
named for Darwin and a copy of it was
sent to Cambridge in England for their
1909 celebrations in which the
deputation that accompanied the bust was
very interested in stressing how
American biologists were as deeply
engaged in the modernizing thrust of
biology as the Cambridge England
scientists expected they were so it was
to show that America to participated in
this grand movement and another copy
this one here was erected on the
Galapagos Islands in 1935 to commemorate
a hundred years after Darwin's visits
there in 1835 and that's an action that
has a different purpose again it in that
in the 1930s
the early years of the World Wildlife
Fund actually the precursor of the World
Wildlife Fund was putting political
pressure on Ecuador to turn the whole
archipelago into a conservation zone and
Ecuador was quite rightly saying but our
fishery industry is based on those
Islands and it will substantially
undermine the Ecuadorian balance of
payments it was turned into a zone and I
rather think if I looked a little more
into the papers I'd find that America
offered to help subsidize some of the
consequences if the archipelago was
turned into a conservation zone with no
fishing so these statues of various
kinds were intended to some degree to
appropriate Darwin as a famous son to
valorize participation in front line
biology and to substantiate the
internationalization of modern science
Darwinism itself although not
universally accepted was hardly under
religious pressure at this point op Neil
Marsh who you will all know the great
biologist of Yale and founder of the
Peabody Museum was noted for his
remarkable work under the guidance of
Huxley but the work was his own on the
fossil ancestry of the horse that shows
from the earliest times the horse was an
animal that had digits just like most
vertebrates and that these evolved and
adapted into a single excessively
enlarged one digit which is the at the
horse's hoof today Marsh did this using
the fossil record at a time when the
fossil record was really not very
obvious
something that supported evolution on
not evolution the fossil record didn't
have enough specimens to make a series
like this that is very effective
demonstration of even the possibility of
evolutionary processes so Marcia was
working here at Yale it's on the first
and it's still one of the most striking
examples of how evolution could have
worked Marsh wasn't troubled by
religious controversy at any point so
just moving back to England the Natural
History Museum in London also staked a
claim in the Darwin legend the Heritage
industry of Darwin and after Darwin's
death the museum raised a public
subscription for a marble statue carved
by Joseph poem and I don't know how many
of you have been to the London Natural
History Museum but those of you who have
been will remember that it's designed
very like a cathedral a giant Romanesque
Gothic cathedral with a kind of double
staircase at one end and a gigantic
stained-glass window and at the back
behind you where you come in what could
be if it had been a Cathedral what would
have been a organ loft it's a cathedral
to make sure designed completely without
any evolutionary ideas in mind the
interesting point that I'm going to
bring out here was that this statute by
Joseph poem was placed in the museum
exactly where the altar would be if it
was a cathedral then here is the opening
ceremony and 1885 with Huxley still a
knife stupidly very vigorous the same
ages that portrait by collier that we
saw Huxley unveiling it making some
remarks about the
formative effect of Darwin's theories
and here is the statue you will see in
just a moment the altarpiece but i just
want to show you this in between in 1927
times had changed and the new director
was very conscious of the way genetics
had come to the fore and that Darwin's
work represented something that was
being superseded by the new genetically
based evolutionary sciences Darwin's
ideas looked old fashioned they were
accurate enough but they were not based
on genetics as we know and so here is
Darwin being moved off the altar down
the steps in 1927 and he was moved to a
spot under the stairs which was open to
the public which was the cafe and there
he SAT for many many years when I was a
young woman going to the museum there
was Darwin under the stairs in the cafe
with a Huxley a marble Huxley next to
him also by the sculptor joseph e.m and
then again times change and back in two
thousand eight just in time for the big
Darwin celebrations all over Britain
Darwin was moved back from the cafe to
this altarpiece you see what I mean
about it being just like a cathedral and
Darwin's in front of this green spot you
can just see him there back where he
originally was in the place of honor for
2009 when his work was being celebrated
it's an interesting little history of
changing values in biology now there's
often thought to be a very special
resonance between a writer and their
home or their place and I think this is
particularly justified in the case of
Darwin and
home down house in kent in england it's
a very good example of the reification
of a building or a landscape that become
such an important part of the public
engagement with science at down Darwin
and his family were a very integral part
of the fabric of country life that
characterized the landed classes in
Britain during the middle years of the
19th century and after Darwin's death
they kept the house but Emma Darwin his
wife moved to cambridge also in england
where three of her adult sons lived they
kept the house for several decades more
but they only visited in the summer
months and then eventually they sold it
to a girls school nice big house we
girls private school and the sons by
then were married they had families of
their own and they played a prominent
role in cambridge university life and
much of this is written about by gwen
rather at one of one of darwin's
granddaughters but also one of the four
children of george darwin and his
American wife Maude Dupuis who came from
Philadelphia this is Gwen Gwen rather at
who became a noted artists as an adult
part of the Bloomsbury set and she
captured what was a very privileged and
innocent childhood in Cambridge with
much charm she included anecdotes about
her hypochondriac aunts and uncles and
father which you see here here is
Henrietta Darwin Darwin's daughter
Henrietta aunt Ettie completely had
konjac in her later life with a little
mask over her nose so that she wouldn't
catch any germs from the maid it's her
patent antique old mask and here is our
debt again ordering I'm sorry she's
gardening here
with Gwen as a child in a damn house so
dad house features quite a bit in Gwen
radrats memoir but she actually lived in
a house in Cambridge with george darwin
her father a very handsome house on the
river that's now a university college
named after the Darwin family it's
another form of commemoration that
deserves mention now the house to stay
with a house for a moment the house
remained as a girls school through the
First World War and then in 1927 Sir
Arthur Keith who we met briefly as one
of darwin's biographers last Thursday
Arthur Keith lived in a house very close
to Darwin's original home and was a
paleoanthropologist author Keith
declared that this house needed to be
secured for the nation it ought to be
turned into a museum of some kind and
there were a number of factors behind
that key that year 1927 scientists had
celebrated the bicentenary of Newton's
death Isaac Newton's death with a
ceremony in Lincolnshire plenty of
self-congratulatory newsprint and a
reverential letter from Albert Einstein
saying you Englishmen have carefully
cultivated bonds of tradition and
preserved the living and conscious
continuity of successive generations
Einstein was talking in relation to
Darwin I'm sorry in relation to Newton
and Keith turned that around and applied
it to Darwin and saying that what was
due to physics should also be due to
biology and that when Newtonian went
that Darwinian should follow so there
were many many financial difficulties
and I won't go into those except to say
that there was a remarkably
generous act offered by the very famous
geneticist Thomas Hunt Morgan who
offered his Nobel prize money to help
purchase Darwin's home for the nation
and looking through the committee
records there's been there was a I think
rather unnecessary nationalistic
expression of views at that point where
they said that American money ought not
to be used to support a great British
hero so Thomas Hunt Morgan kept his
Nobel cash and the house was eventually
purchased by this gentleman George
Buxton Brown extremely wealthy surgeon
in London who gave it in trust to the
nation the house in trust of the nation
it was furnished with the help of Darwin
surviving children and they've recreated
the old rooms as they remembered them so
it's as accurate as we might hope to get
but it is a recreation and when the
house was opened which you see here in
1929 just a few years later it was from
the first regarded as a secular temple
to the mind of Charles Darwin as they
were then perceived the most important
room in the house was Darwin's study
that you see ad trade this is from the
photo taken in the 1920s so it's pretty
dark but you can see well perhaps you
what you can see but you may not know
that this is all we know about Darwin
study so the modern museum is exactly
like this but it's not at all clear as
they're recreating to a photograph that
might not that is itself a memory in the
minds of Darwin's children it's a lovely
old room I just draw your attention to
the stuffed dog here waiting for Darwin
to
for his walk in the morning and the
afternoon so the drama of this study
that some represents Darwin's mind is
intensified by the presence of the chair
so this is the chair in which Darwin
wrote the Origin of Species there is a
board he didn't use a desk he just used
the Writing Board on his knees this is a
page of manuscript up here an ugly old
chair that was his favorite chair in
which he wrote all his books and
articles so that's if you're a biologist
that's quite powerful seeing the chair
which Darwin wrote there's also Darwin's
thinking path in the grounds of this
house that he wrote about in his
autobiography his daily life included
several turns around this path which was
a circle shape a circuit that if he did
enough turns he could have walked a half
a mile or a mile or a mile and a half
depending on what he thought was
significant for his health so he would
walk here every day and that too has a
lot of memory for biologists when they
go to down that they all want to walk on
the thinking path something very special
to do so here we have a darwin study
recreated in 1927 where he wrote or he
received 14 thousand letters maybe
15,000 letters he produced 16 books he
read reviews he persuaded his visitors
to accept his theory or at least to give
it a chance he dissected barnacles in
here and he observed orchids so it's
here that private theories were
transformed into public knowledge it
represents a center of production and
administration as efficient
just any university laboratory or a
library or a factory or a museum so the
house is something more than just a
pleasant afternoon out it's actually
speaking to us of situated knowledge
sociologists call situated knowledge and
these room sets are full of an absent
presence the same kind of absent
presence that Henry James writes about
in his psychological stories it's very
important in generating the view that
Darwin's work was rooted in his home he
didn't go out to work he didn't need you
he didn't have a man to visit he did it
all at home he didn't have technicians
working with him he had his own stuff he
didn't need to go to a library the books
came to him through the mail or he
purchased them his home was his
laboratory in very significant ways but
it was also a domestic place it was a
comfortable place and it was a
non-threatening place and this image was
very pervasive i want to show you an
imaginary scene or two and tell you well
to mention that there is a sad a sad
story waiting to be told in the work of
the russian biologist Victor of staff EF
who painted a number of imaginary scenes
of Darwin at home to send to the darwin
museum in 1955 1955 is was two years
after stalin's death when mainstream
science and russia was emerging
following the downfall of truth in
Lysenko whose environmental non
Darwinian genetics had been the
predominant scientific motif for three
decades previously so if staff EF paints
these at the time that Russian biology
was opening up again to Darwinism it had
been one of the places where Darwinism
was very much accepted with modification
that had been submerged during Lysenko
time so here is a staff here imagining
from Darwin's autobiography which he had
read in published form one of those
evenings when Emma Darwin played the
piano for Darwin himself and he rested
on the city next to her he had no image
of Darwin's home so they submit the
actual pictures imaginary here he was
imagining what it might have been like
when the letter from Alfred Russel
Wallace arrived telling Darwin that
Wallace had a theory of evolution by
natural selection Darwin didn't know
Wallace had that theory completely
fictitious the room set is not Darwin
study Charles Lyell and Joseph Hooker
was certainly not there but they were
part of the story in getting those two
private works forward to the linnean
society for publication so it's a memory
it's wishing to make a memory about this
particular point of view and the other
thing that stf did was that he painted a
rather wonderful imaginary picture of
Alfred Russel Wallace that is used quite
a lot and you may have seen it it's
taken from Wallace's memoirs published
in nineteen thirteen and and is
scientifically accurate but again
completely imaginary so contrast these
images they're very separate from the
world as we know it
contrast these images of rural stability
with the Ferrari of the Scopes trial in
1925 in Dayton Tennessee that took place
after a state law was passed in in 1925
specifying that it was a misdemeanor and
then here's the words of the law to
teach any theory that denies the story
of the divine creation of man has taught
in the Bible and to teach instead that
man has descended from a lower order of
animal and the American Civil Liberties
Union had been watching Tennessee for
quite a while and were well known as you
will know for supporting civil liberties
in different areas of thought the ACLU
offered to defend any Tennessee school
teacher who was willing to challenge
this new law and it was John Scopes a
very young man he was only 24 a biology
teacher at the high school and who
volunteered to be the accused and he
taught a class using this textbook
George William hunters civic biology
that has 44 pages about evolutionary
theory in it and we are memories of this
event very much colored by inherit the
wind the movie but we do need to think
of this situation this case as a show
trial and it was a test case for the law
especially because of the participation
of the well-known politician and
biblical fundamentalist William Jennings
Bryan who volunteered to prosecute and
Clarence Darrow the prominent criminal
lawyer defense lawyer who volunteered to
defend all of a sudden this small trial
went big time
and our memories are deeply colored by
the movie which is wonderful inherit the
wind produced in the post mccarthy era
and it has its own agenda of
intellectual freedom to pursue but it
does bring the trial to life in a very
vivid way the real-life trial was
accompanied by all kinds of
demonstrations great deal of local and
anti evolutionary feeling that you see
here the bookstore and to evolution
League the conflict hell and the high
school very emotive one could
legitimately say and this wasn't just a
metaphysical debate this was full of
real implications about human ancestry
the implications of ape ancestry were
made very obvious both to the people in
Dayton and in the newspapers reporting
on the case here we have a animal
impersonator I suppose we could say
visiting in order to be photographed at
Dayton whilst the Scopes trial was going
on and here's just an image from one of
the newspapers of the day not guilty I
hope and this is very open this is
science and religion meeting in an
obvious way that is not at all obvious
in the British tradition that I've shown
you and the Scopes trial brought into
focus back into focus the old idea about
a conflict between science and religion
that the two ways of thought were
necessarily in conflict especially where
the origins of human beings were
concerned and this more or less is where
we are today but today we have the
additional factor of rising attention
being paid to creation science and I
wanted to show you this image which
surely you many of you have seen
previously this is a poll it's an
international poll of polls in which the
same question was asked of individuals
presumably only a small statistical
sample of individuals in all these
countries on the left which is not every
country in the world but they're mainly
countries in which evolutionary ideas
are prevalent and the response rate was
tabulated and put together into this
table for publication in 2008 2006
bigger pardon and the people who were
being pulled were responding to the
question have human beings as we know
them developed from earlier species of
animals and as you will see many of the
people up at the top here that was true
yes humans have descended from an
earlier species of animal there's a very
consistent band of people who don't know
don't wish to respond to that question
and a bunch of people in all these
different countries who believed that
humans had not developed from earlier
species of animal and I want to draw
your attention to the United States down
here which bothers me I show this every
year in class and it bothers students as
well we're next to turkey and you think
what isn't it that's happening here in
North America that's this kind of a
response can be so obvious one in three
believes in the in the United States
believes that evolution is false one in
three believes in evolution you can see
this it's quite clear down here and just
about one in three doesn't know so it's
this disturbing in such an advanced
society and I want it to dwell for a
moment before we close on the current
creationist movement which partly must
lie behind these kinds of responses so
the current creationist movement I think
is rather different from the religious
belief systems that were commonplace in
the 19th century when Darwin was
publishing model creationist theory it
was pioneered in the 1970s by Henry
Morris who founded the creation research
society and the Institute for Creation
Research in California and this movement
advocates for the literal truth of the
Bible it opposes evolution and sometimes
it opposes cosmologies as well and it
rejects any great age for the earth and
Morris coined the expression creation
science which is a little bit different
from creationism while creationism you
could imagine that people could believe
in all kinds of different origins for
the whole system that we exist in
creation science has a very specific
meaning in that the people who advocate
this are using science they are
attempting to show that the so-called
science of the universities can be
explained by a different form of science
that is different that is creation
science so Morris coined this term and
he built his institute into a very
wide-ranging organization drawing on the
various forms of evangelical revivalism
mostly located in the geographical south
but not always and since then creation
science organizations have developed
very highly efficient business models
they're based on an abundant cash flow
excellent media usage especially the web
and well-placed political pressure both
localized as in the school boards that
have brought court cases against the
teaching of evolution in schools and in
the wider sense in national political
affairs Pew Research last year for
example showed that seventy percent of
republicans would be less likely to vote
for an atheist in comparison with
forty-two percent of democrats so those
figures have not yet been applied to
whether individuals believe in creation
science or not and as you can imagine
our current political candidates our
presidential candidates are very
reluctant to go out on a limb and say
exactly what they believe because
they're going to be caught out on that
and the creation scientists move there
extensively in the world popular culture
they adopt the motifs of conventional
science such as TV shows mother's books
and magazines websites and more recently
museums and theme parks and one of the
biggest museums is the one run by Ken
Ham the Creation Museum in Kentucky
opened in 2007 at a cost of 27 million
dollars including animatronic dinosaurs
it's a fabulous Museum and seen park so
if you had grandchildren or children to
take their or yourselves it's very
engaging you can have a dinosaur ride
you can look at Adam and Eve in the
creation you can walk through an ark
it's incredibly persuasive for a very
large sector of our society and the rise
of creationism so here's just another
thing about Ken Ham his website is
called Answers in Genesis
so that you can email in and have an
answer to your question sometimes
considerable biological complexity
explained to you so the rise of
creationism has tendered in the last
several decades to promote an either/or
frame of mind either it's the Bible or
its evolution with very little
possibility of harmonization and I think
that they're very it can't be a
beneficial dichotomy to think in this
way here is something biologists are
hard justice and Patek as the creation
scientists and it really can't be good
to have a number of scientists so
aggressively asserting that Darwinism is
linked with atheism so I don't have any
answers to provide I wanted to bring it
to your attention I would like to bring
us back to the point where I began last
week where I began the Terry lectures by
emphasizing that we today still grapple
with the questions that Darwin's writing
opened up 150 years ago I've tried in
these lectures to step aside somewhat
from the actual science that was being
proposed and accepted or criticized to
ask more more general questions about
the assimilation of Darwin's ideas in
popular culture and I've taken us a
starting point the belief that the
material grounds of lived experience
provides avenues of historical access
that go beyond the texts into culture
and the social assumptions of a range of
communities and audiences so I've
touched upon darlings account books his
biographers the portraits today other
visual representation
the commemorations and popular souvenirs
and Tamara something like these for
example we all recognize this kind of
movement from chin to mankind this one
with a humorous twist darlings face that
we've already seen is taken in many many
different media this is a t-shirt Chuck
D and then of course he's used and
photoshopped in different ways for all
kinds of posters he's become part of our
culture in a rather interesting way and
that's where I've been engaged in these
three lectures he is a figure enshrined
in statuary in buildings and in artworks
he's been venerated and utilized which
restores I think an extra dimension to
the histories of Darwinism so the
changing imagery the consumer objects
the needs of his shifting audiences help
us to understand a little more widely
his remarkable scientific theory and the
way that it's been assimilated into
different cultures and it helps us
understand a little more of the
processes of making and circulating
scientific knowledge in all the
complexities of the historical moment
I've hoped in these talks to show that
we're still deeply engaged in the
integration and understanding of the
even dictionary ideas as dwight
harrington Terry so perceptively
realized might be the case thank you
very much
thank you so much Janet for riveting set
of lectures for teaching us so much and
for getting us to think about many very
interesting and complicated questions so
on behalf of the audience the faithful
audience for all three lectures I would
like to give you another round of oh
thank you very
so we now open the floor to questions
and there are microphones on either side
so please feel free to walk up and ask a
question um when and why did Darwin grow
his beard when and why did Darwin grow
his beard Oh 1862 and drink he had
eczema and he was feeling very unwell in
those sick 1860s and decided shaving
with an old razor that it was
aggravating his eczema so he would try
just growing a nice-looking beard and
the first pictures of him with a beard
were taken by Leonard his son and it's a
very handsome little bit physically so
there's something that must happen in
the 1870s or the late 1860's where he
just decides to let it hang out but it's
been going to grow and so yes it becomes
you know he's right down here by the
time he had those last portraits taken
it's a magnificent there thank you for
the question I actually think it's a
really important beard that it conveys
to us if we're just going to do some
visual kind of sociology it does convey
a saintliness a patriarchal oversight of
the natural world of sort of beneficence
that I think contributes to our
understanding of darkness a good man I
don't know that anybody thinks Darwin
wasn't a good man I think the image of
him supports that in an interesting way
thank you
let's hear it for the beard is Janet
would you like to say anything about who
Darwin was replaced by in the Natural
History Museum when he was consigned to
the under stairs now here's a man who
knows his history so the museum the
Natural History Museum in central London
that Peters referring to was built to
the specifications of very well known
comparative anatomist called Richard
Owen who was extremely famous in his own
day that has kind of got a bit submerged
since the Darwinian themes have come to
dominate Richard Owen was not an
evolutionist in any way he believed in
God's plan for nature to be expressed in
comparative anatomy that the parallels
you could see between organisms was
God's plan for nature and he came to
grips with Huxley very prominently after
the origin of species was published in
huxley and Owen fought at every possible
opportunity and enjoyed fighting the one
for non evolutionary ideas and Huxley
for all kinds of evolutionary ideas
associated with freedom of speech and
political radicalism casting God out of
science so what Peter is asking is who
replaced Darwin on the steps of the
Natural History Museum well it was the
Richard Owen statue went back to the
Natural History Museum in 1927 when when
dawn was taken down the stairs to go
into the cafe the Owens statue which is
a very handsome bronze statue went back
there as is his Museum it was his with
him and then he's been he was moved
temporarily for Darwin to go back for
2009
and now Owen is back in his rightful
place so it's interesting and you wonder
I suppose you're a museum director you
know how these things work that you have
to talk to a committee about moving
someday it's not an easy thing to move a
statue and people become accustomed to
seeing what they see and they don't like
it when it's a new statue there what are
your thoughts on the continued use of
the term Darwinism we don't speak of
newtonian ism or Einstein ism do you
think that the term Darwinism a work
counter to wider acceptance of
evolutionary theory thank you you put
your finger on a really important point
because opposition's evolutionary theory
will frequently phrase it in terms of
Darwin and dolan ism and have images of
Darwin which have four homes on and
things like that so that's an easy
target whereas by all justice you know
are not wedded to the theories that were
put forward in 1859 biology has moved
and transformed in such a way that it's
much more reasonable to call
evolutionary biology most evolutionary
biologists call it evolutionary biology
they don't call it Darwinism it's me
that calls it Darwinism because what I
was trying to do was to map a particular
body of thought through the ages and it
gets Darwinism as a label gets dropped
19
probably 1960s really perhaps I've never
actually researched that but now now
that we all have google there's an easy
way of doing that which is called an
Engram and you can type in the word
you're searching for and it goes through
google books looking for the words
you've typed in and you can see how that
word rises and falls in the titles of
books so I can do that thank you but
most evolutionary biologists would
either call themselves interpretive
biologists now or their depopulation
biologists or they would be something
else that they they wouldn't be
Darwinists unless they were celebrating
Darwin day or they were doing something
particularly related to natural
selection let's say yes I was not in
town last Tuesday so I missed your first
lecture and what I was wondering is what
did Darwin initially have in mind when
he set out on that voyage oh he wanted
to connect he was absolutely sure that
he had been chosen because of his
ability to collect very widely specimens
and he had taken a couple of catch-up
lessons with his professors in order to
do that but when he set out he saw
himself mostly as a geologist and took
geological books with him he understood
his role was to be a gentleman
naturalist that the ship would take him
to different places and that his task
was to examine the natural products of
the place so his own sense of what he
was doing was collecting for Great
Britain he was a private individual his
Harbor paid him to go on a trip he was
on the Royal Navy for food and transport
and the Admiralty made a lot of useful
concessions to Darwin so that he seems
to be
official madness that he was an
unofficial naturalist and he imagined
that what he would do when he first set
out was that he would that he thought it
was going to be two years that he would
come back and he would then join the
church as he his family had expected and
he too expected at that point and on
that voyage which was five years
eventually he completely transformed
into a naturalist someone who wanted to
live independently and write and study
so when he came back the idea of joining
the church had completely gone out of
his mind so there's a whole kite it's
five years and he was only 22 so there's
lots of changes to how he imagined the
voyage when he set out to what he
actually achieved by the time he got
back and and did he ever give his
reasons for not following up on his
initial intention to be part of the
church he reflected on it in his
autobiography and he even makes a little
joke about it it's very strange that he
should have been intended for the church
and he said that at through the voyage
his faith gradually declined there were
possibly talks with the captain about
such things he was engaged in reading
very deeply a book by charles lyell on
the physical geology of the earth that
explained the whole of the geology of
the earth with no reference to a creator
he was reading other books similar kinds
so his sense of the explanations for the
natural world shifted from being divine
intervention to completely natural
under the guidance of miles book and he
encountered some other dramatic natural
events like an earthquake and a volcano
erupting he never turned to a religious
explanation for those not during the
voyage he'd lost all that thank you like
the other gentlemen I apologize if
you've covered these and I was unaware
of it but I have to I hope wreck ones
was Darwin at all familiar with or any
of his main followers familiar worth the
work of other naturalist say like burrow
an Audubon that have were a little bit
before him and secondly did the somewhat
hijacked um Darwin I don't know if you'd
call it an antecedent but the use of the
term social Darwinism by economists and
political theorists which sometimes that
further hijacked asst by the
conservative wing of those groups to say
because I'm a millionaire I've evolved
and that proves that I'm the best
there's two very different questions God
should have to remind me the first one
about Audubon and thorough so no he
didn't read them his reading was
confined mostly to the European
tradition and when he was reading books
about nature he tended to go for
Wordsworth's poems for example rather
than thorough throws a little later we
know thorough read Darwin that we and we
also know that Darwin didn't leave her
own so I'm sorry about that he must
surely have looked at ode far but where
would he get access to a notable of
coffee there's one in the Linnean
Society in London it
big book as you know it's not clear that
Darwin needed the information from an
Audubon plate for any of the kinds of
things he was trying to say and the
social Darwinism thank you because that
is something that we should be thinking
about you know it's a phrase that was
invented to describe the application of
competition and survival to humans it's
Herbert Spencer who particularly brings
the expression survival of the fittest
into play although Darwin adopts it from
Spencer so later editions of Darwin's
books have that phrase in it and
although I haven't talked about it at
all there's plenty of scholarly work
that explores the other evolutionary
thinkers in the 19th century including
Spencer who had written about these
kinds of things competition and progress
before Darwin published and so after
Darwin the views of a number of people
get into the same kind of Nexus of
evolutionary thought in which
competition survival progress which
wasn't part of Darwin's scheme and
cutthroat competitive business practices
become part of the same kind of complex
social Darwinism really shouldn't be
called social Darwinism should be called
social evolutionism but then we lose
some of its bite and I know people like
to think that it is Darwin who brings
that about one less bill
thank you so much I just wanted to
follow up on the diagram that you showed
toward the end of the top on belief in
belief or not in evolution in various
countries and I noticed that most of
those countries were from Europe a few
from the Middle East and I just wondered
if you had a sense of what that graph
would look like if it did include more
parts of the world s at this time yes
thank you that's a very perceptive
question there's no Japan and now
they're very few Middle Eastern
countries there's no sovereign Indian
did you see Japan was it in there I'm
sir okay no career so I think if it was
a genuinely global survey now 10 years
later it would be very interesting and
it perhaps wouldn't have that nice
little curve to it then you probably
noticed that the ones up at the top of
the chart were mostly Scandinavian and
the people who put that chart together
used it particularly to advocate for
better science education and you know
I've thought about that I'm not sure
that more science education would change
the culture of the countries in which
these points of view are being expressed
if the American Paul had just done the
Northeast Corridor it would be
completely different so there's a size a
geographical spread issue as well so we
all know Paul's don't really tell us
much except what we want polls to tell
us but isn't that an effective yeah it's
very striking thank you
well thank you thank you again for a
wonderful series of lectures the story
of Lyle's book going along with Darwin
was you read that everywhere but another
great set of books that were being
published at the time was was humble and
humbles voyages and life seems to
parallel Darwin so much did he have any
sense of connection with Humboldt yes he
did thank you for asking that question
so Darwin as a very young man at
university read Humboldt's personal
narrative of his voyage in the
equinoctial regions and was enchanted
both by the sort of derring-do the
adventuring nature of what Humboldt
describes the climbing of the mountains
they measurement the scientific results
that Humboldt bought but also the
ability to express in words an
appreciation of nature and the sublimity
that humbled writes about and Darwin
wished wished so hard to emulate
Humboldt in his own journal that the
mattress voyage we call it voyage of the
Beagle now his own journal of
researchers which was published or forty
years after humbled and Darwin was like
a young boy when he had an opportunity
to meet Humboldt late in humbles life
Humboldt visited London and Darwin went
to see him to have breakfast with him
and they correspond in a tiny bit as
well so that yes Humboldt's a really
important part of darwin's early
impressionable years and there are
scholars who we both know our friends
who suggest it's more than just being an
impressionable moment is that Darwin
somehow picks up the Romantic tradition
that humble represented and translates
it into a more secular kind of vision of
true world that keeps the sublime yes
thank you saves a wonderful question
thank you
you